alors que faire précisément face au
pétrole cher ça ne va pas s'arranger a
reconnu nicolas sarkozy ce matin le
président de la république qui a proposé
une aide d'urgence basée sur la tva on
va y venir dans un instant d'abord très
matinale c'est au marché de rungis qu'il
avait choisi de se rendre comme lors de
sa campagne alexandre kara josé
boulesteix c'est la photo du jour de
l'album élyséen main dans la main régis
nicolas et carla sarkozy ont besoin
à l'extérieur quelques travailleurs
sans-papiers manifestent
vite évacué par les forces de l'ordre du
personnel sur d'aujourd'hui puisque deux
heures du match il est une heure du
matin déjà cela ils ont un goût de
l'effort
il ya bien sympathique sympathique comme
cette france qui se lève tôt celle qui a
fait le succès de nicolas sarkozy
pendant la campagne j'ai voulu montrer
que président de la république il était
là aussi pour ceux qui cassent pas les
abribus qui demande pas de subventions
et petits pourtant la vie difficile j'ai
voulu mettre sous le projecteur
cette france qui travaillent tôt
moi je
barry knap
avec la viande et le fromage quand vient
le tour des poissonniers ça sera
peut-être gens qui chantent à l'audience
c'est comme vous souhaitez
mais vous sauter le café la catin
allez finalement ce sera le café les
mareyeurs ne verront pas nicolas sarkozy
déception sera quand même voulu la peine
qu'ils se dépassent même pourvoir est
précédé par am en outre sur la terrasse
pas trop y penser
6h30 la journée s'achève au pavillon des
fleuves
les plus chaudes heures
treize mois après son élection nicolas
sarkozy a toujours le même goût pour la
campagne
et je vous le dis